hiatus edition of pft live and pft pm
back from one week in south carolina
undisclosed location is undisclosed no
more we're at keowa island it is awesome
there we had a great week was able to do
a lot of content on pft decided to take
a break from the video content
and now
by popular demand or otherwise we're
back with more we got three weeks to go
until pft live and pftpm return to
peacock until then every weekday fresh
videos with information analysis and
whatever else i feel like talking about
during the time that i have until they
pull the plug on the session let's begin
with one of the big stories from last
week that created a lot of discussion a
lot of controversy a lot of hot takes on
either side of the aisle tom brady
the news came out that he played last
season with a torn mcl now one report
said partially torn the other report
said fully torn mike ryan who is the
sports medicine analyst for nbc sports
and sunday night football said basically
there's no difference
because of the mcl a partial tear gets
graded as a full tear grade three full
tear
for grade one or grade two of the mcl it
heals on its own grade three requires
surgical intervention that's what brady
had the amazing aspect of it is number
one that he played apparently all season
with it and number two
that the nfl
and the buccaneers and brady
never said anything to anyone that he
was playing with
the torn mcl as ryan explained it to me
there's a moderate risk of a serious
knee injury when playing with the torn
mcl they can use tape to stabilize the
knee that's what the mcl helps to do
stabilize the knee brady wears that
gigantic brace on his left leg and he's
done so pretty much ever since he toured
the acl and mcl in the first game of the
2008 season but if he had taken a hit
wrong time wrong place wrong
configuration
knee would have potentially imploded acl
potentially would have torn again season
would have been over maybe career over
if you get a torn acl at age 43. so that
explains why the buccaneers didn't wear
on their sleeve the fact that brady was
missing an mcl
that
is a separate question from whether or
not they should have disclosed it and
this is one of the issues the nfl has
dealt with for years
and will continue to deal with
in a significant way as legalized sports
wagering continues to spread throughout
the country because
without full transparency when it comes
to injuries that creates inside
information the existence of inside
information creates an opportunity for
people with gambling interests to try to
get the inside information and that can
lead
to
people who know things
saying things
to people who want to know those things
and at some point
there could be an exchange of
money
or other things
to get the people
to provide the information and it can be
players it can be coaches it can be
agents it can be reporters it can be the
person who's just happening to go by the
meeting room and emptying the trash and
seeing something written on a whiteboard
in a facility there are so many
different ways that inside information
can be obtained and shared with people
who want to know everything they
possibly can know before they set the
betting lines before they make their
bets inside information can make all the
difference and in one case it may not
matter with with brady in the buccaneers
the fact that no one knew he had a torn
mcl didn't matter because the knee never
went
so you could look at it and say well the
inside information really
really means nothing because he played
he played well and they won the super
bowl but it's an example of what can
happen
if teams hide injuries
and if the league doesn't react
aggressively when those injuries are
hidden i was told over the weekend i've
not written this yet at pft but i will
that the nfl understands they need to
basically go back and reimagine the
entire injury reporting function in
order
to best balance
transparency
with player health and safety i mean uh
let's face it and i've heard players use
these terms in the past i don't think
they use them now post bounty gate the
world has changed from the standpoint of
what players and coaches are willing to
say about the inherent physicality of
football but
i've heard it said
when you know a guy has an ankle injury
a knee injury a shoulder injury whatever
we're going to test the injured area so
if
opposing defenses knew that tom brady
had a left knee problem and everybody
knows he had the torn acl and mcl in
2008
they're going to test it and
and look there's a fine line
between acknowledging that privately
saying it publicly creating a big
problem
from a pr standpoint but that's why the
buccaneers didn't put it out there plain
and simple they didn't want opposing
defenses no there was value
in
accidentally hitting that left knee or
maybe saying
like
allegedly the saints did in the 2009 nfc
championship game we're just going to
tee off on the opposing quarterback high
low wherever we hit him we'll take the
flags we'll take the fines because
the end result is the opposing team's
best quarterback can't play anymore so
that's why the buccaneers would hide it
and that's part of the balance the
league has to strike
you want to protect players
from
hits like that that will test injured
areas but you also want to ensure that
there is no inside information that then
can be corrupted
that the process can be undermined that
the sport's integrity can be called into
question and
as i've said time and again
the wrong scandal at the wrong time
is going to result in congress maybe
creating an agency that has oversight of
the various professional sports or a
prosecutor
convening a grand jury and trying to get
indictments of people who misuse this
private information that can be
leveraged for money or whatever
to help gamblers
have a better understanding of what
really could happen during a game so
it's a problem it's an issue i've asked
the league multiple times about the tom
brady situation and given the fact that
the buccaneers didn't disclose the
injury once during the season the leaks
constant responses no comment
and common sense and my experience with
the league office tells me that if the
buccaneers fully complied with the rules
they would just say there's no violation
to say no comment tells me
there's a violation
but
you know i think the league
understands
that especially in an age of legalized
sports wagering if you start letting the
world know that there is cheating on the
injury report that there is some level
of corruption within the sport
that's what gets
legislators and or prosecutors
interested in maybe trying to end those
practices so this is not something that
is going to go away it's something to
keep an eye on whether it's brady or
anyone else the nfl is going to struggle
with this and with all the money the nfl
is going to make off of legalized
wagering moving forward it needs to peel
off a few of those bucks and spend the
time and the money and the effort
necessary to come up with rules and
procedures that will be properly
enforced
that ensure that the integrity of the
game can't be undermined you can you can
undermine the integrity of the game
and you can also undermine the integrity
of the individuals connected to the game
by undermining the betting interests by
having this inside information that is
shared
and and and look it doesn't take many
dots to get to the point where you have
someone who is getting paid by gambling
interest for inside information
to
having someone who is getting paid by
gambling interests to
ensure that the home team doesn't win by
more than six and a half points so they
want to nip this in the butt at least
they should want to nip this in the bud
and one of the reasons i'm banging this
drum is i think it's good for nobody
connected to the sport
if the integrity of the game
or the integrity of the wagering process
gets undermined by the misuse of inside
information
there's very little inside information
when it comes to the future of aaron
rodgers i think he knows what he's going
to do and i think he's going to show up
next week and i think one of the reasons
he's been coy about it is
mark murphy the ceo of the team
meets with shareholders slash
cheeseheads slash fans of the team at
lambeau field
next monday for the annual shareholder
meeting
why would aaron rodgers
want to give
all those fans
a reason to exhale in their knowledge
that aaron rodgers is showing up the
very next day
for the start of camp
let murphy sweat i mean ultimately
murphy's the guy that rogers has a
problem with brian gouda kunst is the
name that surfaced early on once rogers
let it be known that he wanted out but
murphy's the guy who number one is the
ceo and number two as of a few years ago
when goutikus became the gm and mike
mccarthy was still the coach
murphy got more involved in the football
operation there's no way murphy didn't
sign off on the trade up to get jordan
love and i think at some level
murphy tries to manipulate aaron rodgers
i think murphy was happy about tyler
dunn's story in early
2020
2019 excuse me i'm getting my ears a
little bit screwy here but it was 2019
the first year with matt lafleur all the
dirty laundry came out about mccarthy
and rogers and murphy's attitude was
basically hey if this pisses some people
off good
maybe people will be more motivated to
come out and have a big 2019 season and
they did and then last year
the drafting of jordan love pissed off
aaron rodgers what happens he's the mvp
now the question is what will they do
when he shows up this year and i still
believe
that murphy would rather move on with
jordan love murphy would rather aaron
rodgers not show up you know if he
doesn't show up
they they avoid 14.9 million in salary
assuming he doesn't show up at all this
year they can collect 11.5 million in
unearned signing bonus money and there's
another 6.8 million that's available
in a roster bonus that he's earned but
they won't have to pay him and you look
at their balance sheets they lost like
38 million last year well they'll make
back 35 million of it or thereabouts if
rogers just doesn't show up i think
murphy would prefer he doesn't if he
does
that could be the moment that the door
opens for a potential trade because it
could be that psychologically the
packers at the top of the organization
don't want to have
the aaron rodgers farewell tour usually
you see a farewell tour under
circumstances where
the guy is going to ride off into the
sunset with a gold watch and he's not
going to play for anybody else and i
know that we saw that a little bit
differently with brady two years ago but
with tom brady no one really knew with
certainty he was leaving the patriots it
started to become
a little more obvious as the season
progressed but it wasn't something that
that hovered so conspicuously over the
franchise from the first day of camp if
rogers reports
on the first day
that cloud is going to hang over green
bay until the end of the season this
idea that he's done after this year
and yeah hey look maybe
they can push the buttons and pull the
cords in a way that gets aaron rodgers
sufficiently pissed off that he takes
the package to the super bowl and wins
it but along the way
man it's gonna be a long year for mark
murphy it's going to be a long year for
brian goodkin so it's going to be a long
year from outlaw who's going to be
caught in the middle
between the lingering animosity and you
know if aaron rodgers shows up it's not
going to be like
russell wilson in seattle who has
completely slammed the door
on the things
that were bothering him back in february
and march he's been able to move on from
it completely and he's all in and maybe
he'll be all out again after this season
but for now he's all in i think when
roger shows up he may try to say he's
all in he's not going to be all in he's
said too much too much has been reported
too much has been discussed he's not
happy with the upper levels of the
organization that's not going to go away
he's going to be asked about it he's
going to talk about it it's going to
constantly be there and that's why i
think that in a weird sort of way
if he wants to be traded
showing up may be the first step toward
getting
the
executive level of the organization to
say we think that it's in the best
interest of the team to move on to
jordan love look aaron rodgers didn't
show up for any of the offseason program
he skipped the mandatory mini camp he's
he's thinner than he needs to be he
hasn't worked out with any of his
teammates in months
we got a guy who's been working and
working and grinding and ready and we
believed in him enough to trade up in
round one to get him in april of 2020
let's go with him so
don't be shocked if he shows up and
showing up is the first domino in the
path that results in rogers being traded
to the broncos at some point by the
middle of august i'm not saying it's
going to happen but i'm saying that it's
something that we need to pay attention
to roger showing up for camp is not by
any means the end of the story it's the
beginning of a new chapter and it's
going to be the gift that keeps on
giving all year long at least until he's
traded and if he's traded then it takes
on
a new level altogether with the new team
becoming a focal point and the packers
becoming even more interesting to see
what they can do without rogers on the
field
there's plenty of news still coming out
about vaccination rates and roughly a
third of the league now has gotten to
the point where at least 85 percent
of the players have gotten at least one
if not both of the shots
i had thought for a while that the
vaccination rates will go up
as the roster sizes
decrease
with 90 guys
you need a lot more guys to be
vaccinated to get to 85
as you trim from 90 down to 53 and
they've added a couple of steps this
year so it's not one fell swoop like it
had been
but
as you go from 90 to 53
i had believed that the that the rate
would always go up i'm starting to think
it may go down because i'm starting to
think that
the guys who are getting vaccinated are
the guys who know that they need to be
able to say i'm vaccinated in order to
enhance their chances of making the
final 53-man roster that the guys at the
bottom of the roster have figured out
either on their own or with the advice
of family members agents whoever or
maybe off-the-record conversations with
coaches or others in the organization
that if you want to make the team
and you're one of these guys that is
fighting
for the final five 10 15 spots on the
53-man roster you've got to be
vaccinated to have a chance
so it could be
that the increases
in the vaccine rate are
flowing from
the guys at the bottom of the roster
all getting vaccinated to enhance their
chances of making the team which means
as those guys are cut
and as they weed out the back end of the
roster
who's left
the star players
with the big salaries who are important
to the team's effort to win games who
have decided i'm untouchable i don't
need to get vaccinated that's where it's
going to get interesting will that rate
go up or will that rate go down i'm
starting to think there's a chance
that the rate will actually go down as
teams trim from 90 to 53
and and it will put
some key veteran players who have high
salaries who have said i'm not getting
vaccinated at risk of being dumped for a
younger guy that the team is impressed
with based upon training camp in
pre-season and they say hey we're going
to save 6 million bucks for example and
our vaccination rate is going to be a
little bit higher because we're moving
on from a veteran who says no way know
how i'm not getting vaccinated to a guy
who
who says yes i got vaccinated and oh by
the way i'm going to cost you a lot less
in cash and cap space and that's still
important 25 million
net decrease in the cap from last year
to this year even though teams are all
currently under the cap they want to
create cap space where they can that's
another reason for guys who haven't been
vaccinated who think they're untouchable
to think twice about it and maybe just
go ahead and get the vaccine and let me
let me
let me address the broader issue with
getting the vaccine it it is morphed
from being
you know just this idea that hey it's
smart for you to do it and if you
haven't gotten it you should get it into
an emerging public health crisis where
the infection rates are going up in
every state
hospitalization rates are going up death
rate is going up covett is making a
comeback and my concern is as we see the
return of mass mandates in places like
los angeles county
people have moved on from the pandemic
and i think it's going to be so much
harder to get people to go back to
the way that we lived from march of 2020
until may of 2021
that genie's out of the bottle and that
genie is not going back in for a lot of
people and and i can remember the trips
i would make to the grocery store here
and i would see masks on everyone
i think that if a mask mandate comes
back to west virginia or anywhere else
you're gonna have a lot of people who
say
either i've been vaccinated and i'm not
putting a mask back on or
i haven't been vaccinated and i never
wanted to wear masks in the first place
and this thing's over as far as i'm
concerned and i'm just gonna live my
life yada yada yada and and i don't know
how at this point
the people who believe in the
vaccination
can convince the people who don't
believe in it to change their mind i
don't think there's anything that anyone
can say or do at this point to change
their mind and if you watch cable news
the the left-leaning cable news channels
i don't think the strategy of getting
mad and yelling
at unvaccinated people who aren't
watching you anyway
is the way to get them to get vaccinated
i've seen a lot of that
a lot of people getting pissed off and
getting upset
and yelling to an audience that isn't
there because they're yelling to the
vaccinated that the unvaccinated should
get vaccinated i don't know what that
does
to get the unvaccinated
to get the shots it's not going to be
effective
somebody needs to come up with a way to
scare the crap
out of the unvaccinated to pierce
through that shell that has them
refusing to get vaccinated and and i
don't i don't have the answer but i'd
like to think that the upper levels of
the american government all the way to
the president can and should come up
with some sort of an idea here
sorry about that phone call coming
through sorry um but uh somebody needs
to come up with a way to get the
unvaccinated to to do it you know
they've been talking about going door to
door
and there's a concern that the people
who are not vaccinated we'll view that
as you know big brother in 1984 and you
know you may have a shotgun blast coming
through the door if somebody shows up
and i'm not kidding when i say that to
try to get somebody
persuaded to take the vaccine so it's
it's
we assume that everything's fine and
dandy and we assume that the football
season is going to go forward and i
think it will now whether to what extent
we have full stadiums we'll see but i
feel like in so many ways
it's too late to turn back around
but the things i'm seeing and hearing
when i do pay attention to the news and
i and you know i kind of checked out
last week while i was at the beach it's
sobering
and it feels like we're heading back to
a bad spot again and i don't know what
that's going to mean for football season
but it's definitely something to keep an
eye on as august 1 approaches
one last thing about the vaccine
situation which i think will persuade
more players to get the vaccine and
before they do they're going to be
pissed off when they see and understand
what this means
there was a memo recently from the
league to all teams explaining that in
the facilities vaccinated players
are required to be
readily identifiable through a wristband
a credential on a lanyard whatever the
case may be
i'm told that the league in the union
are finalizing plans to allow
someone who has been vaccinated to be
readily identified
on the practice field and on the
sidelines or during games which means
all those players out there who don't
want to talk about the vaccine it's a
personal medical decision it's nobody's
business but mine well
it's going to be obvious who is and who
isn't vaccinated
and
that in and of itself once the players
understand that and the sooner they make
sure the players know that and let them
process it let the ones who don't like
it like cole beasley go to social media
and rant and rave about it and then
realize hey look
if i if i can get away without being
vaccinated no one knows i'll do it but
if everyone's going to know i'm not
vaccinated i'm just going to go ahead
and get vaccinated it may make the
difference for some guys
i'm i'm fascinated by the question
whether tom brady gets vaccinated i
don't think he will he doesn't want any
chemicals anywhere near his body he's
not going to want to have any kind of
chemical injected in his body he thinks
his body is a perfect temple that will
be able to withstand any and all illness
he's not going to get it i think well if
he didn't get it we're going to know
based upon what the union and the league
are currently discussing so keep an eye
on that and i think the sooner the
league in the union make that
information available to players the
sooner that some of them who have been
reluctant to get the vaccine can get it
before they report for training camp
one last point
as it relates to the richard sherman
situation that broke last week when i
was at the beach and we had plenty of
stories about it at pft
and uh
it
it sounds like things are under control
for now and that's good for him and his
family we wish them the best and we hope
this situation can be managed in a
successful way and whatever occurred
last week won't happen again
from a football standpoint
i don't know enough about what's going
on with richard sherman to know whether
it's good for him or not good for him to
be on a team it could be that it's in
his best interest to sign with someone
to get to a training camp and to benefit
from the structure of being in a locker
room with his teammates back in an
environment where he's comfortable where
he's familiar whether it's back with the
49ers back with the seahawks or with a
new team that could help him immensely
at this point
and and my broader point is given the
fact that he's facing five misdemeanors
the nature of the accusations the
facts that resulted in these five
charges the league could decide to put
him on paid leave
and my point is as it relates to sherman
as it relates to sean watson as it
related two years ago to antonio brown
the league should not use
the potential of paid leave as some sort
of a guessing game
and oh hey you know hey if if the saints
are interested in signing richard
sherman and they contact the league
office will you tell us whether or not
he's going to be put on paid leave no
we're not going to tell you well why
wouldn't you tell
the saints or anyone else whether or not
that's going to happen because in a
situation like that
it operates as a deterrence just like
you did with antonio brown he served a
14-game unpaid suspension as a practical
matter because the league wouldn't tell
any of the teams that were interested in
antonio brown whether or not he was
going to be put on paid leave for the
accusations he was facing at the time
and that's just wrong just let everyone
know where the guy stands he'll be put
on paid leave or he won't be put on paid
leave and for richard sherman
if the league refuses to say so that
becomes a potential impediment to him
joining a team so
that's why i believe as to sherman as to
watson as to brown as to any other
player who possibly could end up on paid
leave the league needs to conduct the
preliminary investigation under the
personal conduct policy come to a
decision and even if a guy currently
isn't signed by any team let everyone
know what his status is going to be so
everyone can make the right decisions
all right i've gone on longer than i
thought i was going to
shocker
i want to answer some of these questions
though because we've got a few in here
this is sight unseen as usual
and uh we'll see if there's anything
here
that
is non-sarcastic
um
brandon elkins aaron rodgers knew he
wouldn't be traded this off season
coming off an incredible season of being
the mvp i think he's created all this
drama to set the stage to be traded next
off season knowing that's more realistic
thoughts hey i don't disagree with that
concept and peter king made the
suggestion weeks ago of a very simple
solution packers say to aaron rodgers
come back this year and play this year
and after the season will trade you i
think the packers get more trading him
after the season than they would get
trading now but i think at some level
mark murphy doesn't want him there and
if he shows up there's a chance the
packers soften in there we're not
trading you mindset because i think they
would just prefer at this point not to
go through the full season of drama
driven by aaron rodgers
philip krajewski will chris sims
remember to show up for work or continue
to wake and bake uh we got three more
weeks until sims has to come back it's
just me for the hiatus edition but i i
fully expect that sims will be back and
ready to go and back into retox full
detox for three more weeks re-talks as
of august 9. sean alvashad this is an
important question what are your
thoughts on james gandolfini almost
replacing steve carell on the office i
first became aware of that
reading the book that i mentioned a
couple of weeks ago the oral history of
the office and i had no idea how close
it was between james gandolfini and
james spader to be the new boss post
michael scott steve carell and the extra
bit of news that came out last week and
i saw this tweeted by jimmy trayno of
si.com
nbc offered gandolfini 4 million to do
it
hbo paid him 3 million to not do it so
that would explain why i didn't do it i
think it would have been awesome i think
it would have been spectacular
and
i think those last few seasons of the
show
would have been remembered a lot more
fondly than they are really from the
moment michael scott
let me step back
after pam and jim got married
it kind of started
to creep downhill after they had the
baby it started to accelerate after
michael scott left that's when it fell
off the cliff
and i don't really remember much about
the last two seasons i watched them i
remember not liking it and i remember
feeling compelled to keep watching
because
of the fact that i'd been invested for
so long and and i think it wouldn't have
been that vibe if it had been james
gandolfini instead of james spader at
the at the end of the series
uh let's see
matt and saint pete what would have to
happen for the nfl to take action
against the bucks for the brady mcl
situation for all we know they're going
to
for all we know they're going to do it
secretly you know a couple of years ago
the steelers and coach mike tomlin got
penalized by the league fined by the
league for not disclosing ben
roethberger's elbow injury and that
elbow went out during week two
of the 2019 season and there were fines
that were imposed the nfl does not like
to aggressively enforce that rule
because as i said earlier the league
doesn't want people to realize how
widespread the violations are of the
injury reporting rules and they are
widespread
brandonfield97 uk fan would you ever
consider coming to london and doing a
special pft podcast when the annual
london games are on i mean the problem
is the london games happen during the
regular season and we're here
for football night in america and the
time change and the travel it just
doesn't work we want to come to london
we were getting ready to come to london
before the pandemic once the pandemic is
finally over whenever that may be
we're coming to london i guarantee you
that james mcdonough otherwise known as
at dr j144 do you see this season going
well for cliff kingsbury and steve kahn
i live here in arizona and think they're
clearly the first fourth best team in
the division i'm not as optimistic as
some are nationally i remember when the
cardinals used to be
in the nfc east prior to 2002
that was their division
they'd be the best team
in the nfc east right now you take the
cardinals and put them in with the
cowboys giants eagles in washington
cardinals are the best team nfc west
i would say
yeah they are the fourth best team
because the rams the 49ers and the
seahawks are so good and
i with seven playoff teams per
conference there is a chance every team
in the nfc west could get a playoff
berth now that would mean no team other
than the division champions for the
other three getting in but it could
happen stranger things have happened uh
maybe not that strange as having all
four teams from a division in the
playoffs but it could happen i think if
the cardinals don't make it to the
playoffs this year though the cardinals
are going to move on from cliff
kingsbury the cardinals have a long
history of not sticking with coaches
uh for an extended period of time
only two coaches in the history of the
organization have ever made it six years
jim hanafan from 80 to 85
and ken wisenhunt who took the team to
the super bowl
bruce erin's made it five years this is
year three for kingsbury i don't think
he gets a fourth one if they don't make
it to the playoffs this year you're
already picking up on that vibe that
frustration that irritation from guys
like kyler murray and and i think this
is it for kingsbury kai may survive
but i don't think kingsbury does if they
don't make it to the playoffs this year
and it is going to be a difficult thing
to have happen
pfdp and policy as we continue to see
the number of competent franchise
quarterbacks increase when
or will we start to see them devalued
like franchise running back say you know
i i don't think we're going to see
quarterbacks get to the point where
the supply
greatly outweighs the demand that's what
we see with running backs
and i think we're we're going to start
to see that with receivers because there
are so many great receivers that come
out in the draft every year teams are
going to be reluctant to pay huge money
to their star receiver knowing that they
can just go find another one because so
many guys every year are making an
impact right away in the nfl with
quarterbacks
i think what we're going to see is
a greater willingness to not give market
value money to a guy on a second
contract and it may be one of the
reasons why baker mayfield lamar jackson
josh allen don't have their second deals
yet
you don't have that same compulsion to
lock up with the second contract
a quarterback who's landed on the pass
side of pass fail as to whether or not
he's a bust i think teams now have the
luxury to wait and see
whether that player is going to be a
true
list franchise quarterback because if
he's not
maybe you don't want to break the bank
for him maybe you want to think about
your options and it's one of the reasons
why so many veteran quarterbacks are
available every year
teams want to find a franchise
quarterback they're willing to move on
from a guy who is good enough but not
great enough in the hopes of finding a
guy who will be the answer for 10 or 15
years or longer and with so many
college quarterbacks coming out now who
are competent and ready to go coaches
willing to embrace the systems that
those quarterbacks thrived in at the
college level
that's what's making teams
less inclined to overpay
a guy who is just average middle of the
pack everyone wants that franchise guy
who is among the very best in the league
and teams are willing to let the bird in
the hand fly away in search of the two
in the bush because if all else fails
they'll find another bird in the hand
out there somewhere all right
let's uh
let's see what else we got here probably
should wrap this up i'm looking for a
good one looking for a good one uh
let's see here
some some of these are funny i'm not
going to read them out loud i like the
fact that people have a sense of humor
can anyone improve their accuracy like
josh allen did from year one to year
three ever again that's jp's kubinski
i i don't know
that look i don't know how much of it
was josh allen
suddenly becoming a better quarterback
as it was
the bills surrounding him with the
talent that allowed him
to become a better quarterback you go
out and get staphon digs you get a high
end receiver all of a sudden your
quarterback looks a lot better you know
one of the knocks on josh allen coming
out of college was his accuracy was not
good well his receivers were not good
at some level
the guy who is commissioned to run the
route and catch the pass has to do his
job or the quarterback's going to be the
one who bears the brunt of the
incomplete passes so
yes josh allen year three hit a level
that people had assumed based on year
one and two he wasn't going to reach and
that shows
the flaw i think of
coming to
hard and fast conclusions about a guy's
ability based upon one or two years in
the nfl
now now i know that
teams are less patient than they've ever
been with quarterbacks and really
players at any position you used that
first round pick on a guy you wanted to
come in and make an impact right away
but yeah for some guys it takes a little
bit to get to their ceiling it takes
some help to get to the third uh year
and have that great season like allen
did so
yeah i could see other quarterbacks
coming in and not having to help around
them the first couple of years and by
year three they have the help around
them and off they go that's what they
expect daniel jones to do this year for
the giants they expect him to have no
excuses with the first round pick used
on cadarius tony the money that was
spent to bring in kenny galladay
saquon barkley back if and when he's
back he recently said he's not sure when
he's going to be ready to go but
they want daniel jones to have that same
kind of jump this year and if he doesn't
gets back to the prior question from pft
pm posse i think the giants will be
inclined at that point to say hey daniel
we're not giving you a second contract
we'll go find somebody else maybe we'll
keep you for four years maybe we'll keep
you for five years but after that we're
going to move on and we're not going to
make the mistake of paying you 30 or 35
million just because we fear
not having someone else who's as good
will find someone else who's as good
because there's so many veterans out
there this is the new normal
every free agency now i believe there
will be
more than a handful of quarterbacks with
recognizable names who are available to
be signed or guys out there who could be
traded for because teams recognize the
younger quarterbacks coming into the
league better than ever before all right
that's it for today we'll do it again
tomorrow we'll do it every day this week
we're getting ready for the olympics
which launched this weekend but we're
still going to carve out some time for
the pft live pft pm
daily hiatus version of everything
happening in the nfl thanks as always
for some of your time and we'll talk to
you again tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports